[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yep, I
am catching some Pokemons.
Yeah, you know,
"Pokemon Go" is crazy.
Millions of people play this
game, and it scales like that.
Did you know that it was
built on Google Cloud?
Well, let's talk to technical
manager at Niantic Labs
to take a behind the scenes look
at "Pokemon Go"'s architecture,
and how it scales for a
large number of players.
Hi, James, welcome to the show.
JAMES PROMPANYA: Hi,
thank you for having me.
I'm excited to be here.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, for those
who may not be familiar
with "Pokemon Go,"
let's quickly go
over what it is.
JAMES PROMPANYA: So
"Pokemon Go" is not
your typical mobile game.
It's a game that involves
walking around, catching
these little creatures around
you called Pokemon that are
appearing in the real world.
It encourages you to go
outside, explore, and discover
things using augmented reality.
A big part of that
which wasn't included
in the game when
it first came out
was this big community
aspect of it.
Players would go out and meet
with other players in real life
to play together,
battle in gyms,
and even like point
it out when there
was this rare, powerful Pokemon
that would appear somewhere
in your map.
Everyone sees the same Pokemon.
So you even see this in like
YouTube clips out there,
but sometimes somebody
would just yell out,
hey, there's a
Charizard here, and you
would see crowds of Pokemon
running towards that direction.
So nowadays we really like
this part of the game.
So we made it a major part by
hosting regular live events,
such as community days,
raid hours, Team Go Rocket
takeovers.
It all culminates in
this big summer event
that we call Go Fest.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So it's
clear that lots of people
are playing at any given time,
especially during Go Fest.
How does "Pokemon
Go" back end actually
scale to handle these
peaks in traffic?
JAMES PROMPANYA: So
we use Google Cloud.
We have lots of services
that need scaling,
such as the Google Kubernetes
Engine and Spanner.
Our front end service
is hosted on GKE.
And it's pretty easy to
scale the notes there.
Google Cloud provides
us with all the tools
we need to manage the
Kubernetes cluster.
The Cloud Console is
just really easy to use
and comes with detailed
monitoring, graphs, tools,
logging all included.
And it's just a few clicks away.
In the past Go Fest we
had Google engineers
virtually sitting
with us side by side
and ready to tackle any issues
that could come from the event.
It was like having an extra
support team working directly
for us.
To give an idea of scale, we
have about 5,000 spanner nodes
handling the traffic, and
thousands of Kubernetes
nodes running just for
the "Pokemon Go" service.
We also have the
various microservices
that host other parts of the
game that help augment the game
experience.
All of these work together
to support millions
of players playing the game all
across the world at any given
moment.
And if you compare
ourselves to like,
maybe "World of
Warcraft," you'll
see that other massively
multiplayer online games,
they split players
into multiple realms.
But for us, all of our players,
they reside on a single realm.
It was important for us
that the players can always
interact with each other
and share the same game
experience no matter where
or when they're playing.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Yeah, it's like making
sure it's one same world,
and one same similar
view that you're sharing with
all the players, which is
what makes the game so amazing.
You mentioned Spanner and GKE.
Was it always Spanner and GKE?
Or did you decide to make
that architectural decision
as the game got popular?
JAMES PROMPANYA: So we
actually started off
with Google Data Store.
It was an easy
way for us to just
get started without
having to worry
about another piece
of infrastructure
that we needed to
manage, and scale,
and deal with all those things.
However, as the game
matured, we decided
that we needed more control
over the size, and the scale,
and performance of the database.
So when we were looking
at different providers,
we saw that Spanner has
consistent indexing that
allows us to do more
complex database
schemas with these primary
and secondary keys.
Data Store was
also non-relational
with atomic and
durable transactions.
So we needed a relational
database with full consistency,
and made the choice
to go to Spanner,
which gave us these
global asset transactions.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well, it's
great to see that you started
off with a single back end
that worked at the time,
and then quickly evolved
that architecture to include
the components that made
more sense as the game grew.
Now, let's say I am a player.
And I'm playing
the game right now.
I open my app to
catch a Pokemon.
What is happening
behind the scenes?
How does the request flow work?
JAMES PROMPANYA: When the
user catches a Pokemon,
we receive that request through
the Google Cloud load balancer.
All of the static media is also
stored on Google Cloud Storage
buckets and is downloaded
to the phone when you first
start the app.
We also have caching enabled
at the load balancer.
So it's all cached and served
through Google Cloud SDN.
So when the player
catches the Pokemon,
the GCLB sends a request
to our GKE cluster.
And we have a front
end service that sits
behind a Nginx reverse proxy.
The request goes from the user's
phone to the reverse proxy,
to one of these player
front end services.
We also have this thing called
a spacial query back end.
It's a cache by location.
So that is where we store the
information that determines
where a Pokemon is
shown on the map, what
gyms and Pokestops are around
you, what time zone you're in,
or any other feature
that is location-based.
The way I like to think
about it is the front end
manages the player and their
interaction with the game,
while the spatial query
back end handles the map.
The front end retrieves
the information
from the [? squibby ?]
to send back to the user.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
the spatial back end,
it sounds like it's a custom
database of sorts that presents
the map and the Pokemons.
Now, what happens when I hunt
a Pokemon down and catch it?
JAMES PROMPANYA: When
you catch a Pokemon,
it sends the request to the
front end to the Spanner
Database where your player
entity is stored in the store
there.
For catching Pokemon,
that actually
doesn't go to the
spatial query back end.
If you were instead
battling in a gym,
or adding lures to the
Pokestop, that information
is stored on the
spatial query back end.
And then the data gets
eventually consistent,
at which point the players
will receive the update.
And then it's used for
all the other players
that are in your vicinity.
The front end at that point
will retrieve the information
from the spatial query back end
and send it back to the user.
We also store this
information using Protobuf
and additionally, we
also write this data
into Bigtable, which we also
use for logging and tracking
purposes with very strict
retention policies.
We also use Pub/Sub to
send kind of a message
to a Pub/Sub topic,
which is then
used for an analytics pipeline.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So how
do you ensure that when
two people who are in the
same geographic regions
see the same Pokemon data, and
keep that relatively in sync,
especially during the events?
JAMES PROMPANYA: So it's
actually pretty interesting.
Everything in our servers
are deterministic.
So even if players are
on different machines,
they are sent to different
front end services,
if they're in the same
physical location,
all the inputs
would be the same.
And the same Pokemon would
get returned to both users.
There's a lot of
caching involved,
and as well as precise timing,
especially when the settings
are changed and they need to be
in sync across all the servers.
So it's very tricky, but it
was very important for us
that all the players
feel like they're
part of this one shared world.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Speaking of analytics,
we talked a little
bit about Pub/Sub.
And you're sending
these messages
into Pub/Sub for analytics.
Now, there's a massive
amount of data that must
be generated during the game.
How does data analytics
pipeline work?
And what are you analyzing?
JAMES PROMPANYA:
Yeah, you are correct.
There's like 10 to
20 GB of data that
gets generated on a daily
basis, and stores all of it
into BigQuery.
This game data is of interest
to our data science team.
They use this for marketing
purposes, for verification.
For example, we might want to
say that this player or players
caught X millions
amount of Pokemon
during our Saturday
community day events.
So it's important that
we have that information
in an easily accessible manner.
We also use Dataflow as
our data processing engine
to run batch jobs to
process the player logs
that are sitting in Bigtable.
One example of that is
using cheat detection.
We might look through
logs and notice
that a player used
to be in Japan,
and then a minute later
they were in Australia.
So we want to check
for that, and make sure
that we're responding to
improper player signals.
On the other side
of things, we also
use Google Dataflow to set
up Pokestops, and gyms,
and habitat information
all over the world.
We take in information
from various sources,
like OpenStreetMap, the
US Geological Survey,
and Wayfarer, which is
our crowdsourced website
for players to submit
points of interests
in their neighborhood, and
combine all that information
to build a living
map of the world.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Now,
as the events grow,
like you mentioned, in
some of these events
the traffic grows to
millions of users per second.
You also said 10 to 20
GB of data is generated.
How does the system scale when
it comes to data pipeline?
JAMES PROMPANYA: Yeah, so with
this increase of transactions
there is increase of load
throughout the system
with a lot of our
data pipelines.
For things like BigQuery,
a lot of that just works.
Google Cloud will handle
the increase in traffic
without any intervention.
Some of the other
things we'll just
scale preemptively
and make sure we
work with Google to
make sure that we
can support that traffic.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
With that much traffic,
obviously the health of the
system is critical as well.
How do you monitor the
health of the system
during these massive events?
JAMES PROMPANYA: So we use
multiple monitoring systems,
including Prometheus, Grafana,
and Google Cloud Monitoring.
On a personal level,
I actually prefer
to Google Cloud
Monitoring, because it's
very simple to use.
For me, it's very
easy to set up graphs,
to set up alerts, and
not have to get really
into the nitty gritty
details of some
of these other implementations.
Everything just is very easy to
use in Google Cloud and Google
Cloud Monitoring.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
it was awesome to hear
the entire implementation
and the architecture details.
I am very sure you
have something in mind,
or you're cooking up something
to evolve this architecture
right now.
What are some of the expansions
and improvements you're
looking to do in the future?
JAMES PROMPANYA: On the
Google Cloud side of things,
we are looking into things
such as Agones and Google Game
Servers, and using
that to see how we
can make our game even better.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: We wish
you and the Niantic team best
of luck for these enhancements.
And this has obviously been
super insightful for us, James.
Thanks for joining me today
and sharing your architecture
with us.
JAMES PROMPANYA: Yeah,
thanks for having me.
This was fun.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
we just took a behind
the scenes tour
into "Pokemon Go"'s
architecture, how they use
GKE and Spanner for scaling
to those high peaks, and how
their data science team works
with BigQuery, Dataflow, and
Pub/Sub for the data analytics.
Want to learn more?
Check out the links below.
Like and subscribe while I
catch some more Pokemons.